Duncan can own it right there give M Mr
dunan my
own I'll huff and I'll puff and I'll
blow your house
in here's Chad
horror movies don't work with a
[Music]
Walther we have obtained the Nashville
Shooters Manifesto as we again make
complete fools out of the talls in the
media it's just so easy Joe Biden
supports gender reassignment for
children marks wouldn't be further to
the left Trump is not part of the
Republican
party we had Barack Obama they ran a
poll now I believe that marriage is
between a man and a woman that's why I'm
married clearly to what is it's no
secret a woman everybody
knows it's a valid question
[Music]
valid say what again
sa one
[Music]
[Applause]
again I
[Music]
know
glad to be with you and uh yes that is
correct Dan Bonino and I will be
crossing the streams this Thursday I'll
be on his show he'll be on this show so
um yeah you
know dirty Guinea deserves an
opportunity every now and
then and we have the ability he's in our
studio affectionately he is in our
studio so we have the ability to dump
him whenever we want but he's kind of a
friend all right so let to get to uh I
know it was a busy weekend for uh many
of you um it especially for a lot of you
you know uh like out virtue signaling
each other on Veterans Day yeah I love
that people like you know man you
couldn't I just said Thank You sincerely
thank you that's all I put out there
people like you couldn't do
more these people have been out there
killing terrorists yeah what am I gonna
say other than thank you so anyway lot
to get to here is the Photoshop rundown
so everyone can kind of see and follow
along uh Tim Scott is done a I know I
know I know another one who's gone too
soon but that's an expensive exit how
many millions of dollars raised 2% uh
we're going to have an empire state of
crime segment uh the Vigilante and many
of you refer to him as a hero some refer
to him as a vigilante I refer to him as
a hero has been arrested for firing a
gun at a man who was assaulting a woman
there was a Las Vegas teen beaten to
death the media is covering this
um well they're either not covering it
or they're just omitting the race of the
perpetrator and the victim guess why and
then we are going to be doing we haven't
done this in a while this is a thorough
a toz debunking of John Oliver his
segment on Israel and Hamas uh I'm
pretty sure you can guess where it goes
nice so uh I'm adjusting my headphones
here number two Gerald well actually
first let me ask you this considering
how stopping a crime has caused so many
Good Samaritans to go to jails in in in
Liberal cities and of course the jails
are empty because actual criminals are
on the street if you saw crime happening
today would you
intervene would you try and be a Good
Samaritan that's a cultural shift that
I'm worried about in this country people
say you know what n it doesn't involve
me I don't want to do it yeah so comment
below uh Gerald a number two how are you
I'm doing well how are you fine yeah
yeah neck thing gone it's not gone but
it's I'm working on it you are I'm
working on it you working on you and
your mustache yeah working on the
mustache I had the perfect Civil War
thing going like you know this deal
where it's a beard above your beard but
the problem is I was trying to trim it
and I cut a chunk out so it just my hair
wouldn't look right yeah that's what it
was and in third share brings a smile to
her face when you hear this you know who
it is you love them Sunday November 19th
you will be at the Bricktown comedy club
in Tulsa Oklahoma you can follow Josh
firestein for his other dates joshh how
are you sir I'm good I'm good how are
you thank you for your service thank you
oh yeah you could have done more you
could have done more could have done
more sent me a cake or you could have
what yeah I don't know that was on the
list two more thank yous could have just
paid your taxes that would have been
sufficient also we 15 thank
yous is that tough for you on Veterans
Day because everyone is stepping over
themselves like thank you no thank you
no I thank you no thank well thank thank
you I'm grateful my favorite is that
when everybody changes their Facebook
profile picture to like their uh their
basic training or boot camp photo when
guy 45-year-old guy was 18 yes that's
true just randomly changing like why did
you what you want me to thank you yeah
oh my gosh thank you so much in Gerald's
case he changed his display picture to
his dishonorable discharge
papers I didn't know you could get those
before you made it in I know a guy who
does that he got dishonorably
discharged and he does it on Veterans
Day every year seriously I have to
respect him he didn't even make it out
of boot camp he got dishonorably
discharged from boot camp do we have to
thank him for his service tech okay
speaking of boot camp it's time to
quickly address this this is all over
the place it's it's more uh boob g oo as
in breast a Sig so there's a podcast
host the guy named Adam 22 I don't know
if that's his real name and uh Adam was
he has a wife yeah Adam was already
taking Lena the plug which again I'm not
sure I'm going by their their Studio
their Hollywood nomenclature so you know
he's the guy who talked about you know
uh renting his wife out to uh other
people and now to really highlight this
in case you wondered in case you ever
wonder as to um you know the decay of
Western civilization and you ever wanted
to have the thought cross your mind of
you know maybe Hamas isn't all wrong
they're debuting my God I think Islam is
a a new reality show to find a man for
her to
um uh consummate with I am Lena the plug
I am an adult Creator my name is Adam 22
and I co-own plug talk with my lovely
wife it's a low caliber
every week them at the end but we've
only ever done it with other women so
we've arranged this whole challenge to
find a perfect guy to be our first ever
boy boy girl through take us so long to
get this improved on
YouTube it's on YouTube on YouTube that
well I guess that brings us to a new
segment we'll be doing uh age
appropriate or not douchebag
Edition
[Music]
yeah we're not going to play the game
it'll just be
him it'll just be Adam 32 ACP Adam 22
times Lena the 380 Adam 22 guys
my wife whoa hey look this is a thing
it's just this guy he's a digital pimp
he's a digital pimp this is the problem
with modern dating it's like not
everything needs to be a veritable Meat
Market
no it's just disgusting it took me a
second very Lady likee it's not and
after the incident he rewarded his wife
with a $400,000 Lambo is what they call
it because he was so proud of her okay
first off don't call it a Lambo
second I don't know that that's a
$400,000 C but okay let's go with it uh
third proud proud of I mean the if there
could ever be honey you took it like a
CH a lesser
accomplishment How brave of her a lesser
accomplishment that I can think of would
be being an attractive woman saying yes
to sex with a random stranger like
that's the opposite of an accomplishment
the accomplishment is saying no because
like like you know you're just you just
gave away the price for free yeah also I
don't think she's doing most of the work
in there no no I think that she's she's
the plug yes I don't think that's what
she's doing I wouldn't even give her a
participation trophy i' correct it with
a big red marker lying liar
liar and you know it it's true
they know you never whole series on this
they're doing a whole series gu to sleep
with my wife and everyone's like oh this
is great and they always inevit they'll
tell you right inevitably like oh you're
against this because you're jealous
because you don't have a woman as hot
it's like yeah neither does Adam 22 so
the the end is just sex yes well yeah
basically open open degenerate
relationship that's how I don't want to
judge people you know it's funny to make
fun of sure it's funny to make fun of
but I do I do want to point out that
I've never met somebody in their 50s
that was like hey this is my wife Martha
and uh the guy she's been banging for 5
years exactly the guy I've been banging
for three our marriage has never been
better we're so happy help me we are so
happy well she's namely happy with other
people uh and I'm happy in the corner
but find joy in living vicariously
through others that's why I give her a
$400,000 Lambo every time she courts uh
a black pornography actor Dick that is
insecurity at its finest I know and he's
like I'm so secure I'm so secure that
I'm letting her that I'm that I'm but
you know I'm just this is just I'm so
secure what are you so insecure you
wouldn't let your wife have sex with as
many strangers as she wants I I guess so
yep I you wouldn't even buy your wife a
Lambo no I wouldn't she want a rap four
true yeah yeah also I I don't want to
deal with Repo Men
yeah it's a
lease going to his accountant like uh
can I get some kind of write off as a
gift with this depends what was it for
banging a porn star I don't know if
that's deductible but I got news for you
your wife's probably a uh we're
proud of her though yeah H&R
[Laughter]
Block by the way if we haven't done this
yet if you're watching right now and
you're watching on YouTube which why are
you doing that go to rumble And
subscribe over there yeah you might see
this which means head on over uh to
rumble okay we'll move on from that you
guys can comment below I guess we're
just old sticks in the mud you know
believing that you shouldn't you
shouldn't uh sleep with random strangers
if you're married uh all right old
tradition old me Mr traditional they're
not random strangers they're going on a
quest to find love yes
exactly they have a whole show even it's
on YouTube it makes flavor flaves
reality show look like church yeah I
want to watch that
nowz at least he was trying to find love
even with his stupid clock and catch
phrases he was never on time he's known
for the clock watch Yo that guy is
married yeah your Flavor Flav would be
dis can't say the word all right
speaking of flavor flave Tim Scott has
dropped out of the presidential race I
don't get the connection and uh that
means it's time to close
former president Donald Trump still
leading the polls by a large margin
while Scott pulled just 2% among
Republican voters time to
close endings and Beginnings are ending
and beginning now I thought he started
off on theong on the right foot on that
issue it
is no no no not here I'm sorry sir do
not boo this is the view we accept we
don't have to believe everything people
say but you cannot boo people here
please how's everyone doing today when I
go back to Iowa it will not be as a
presidential uh candidate I suspending
my campaign I know that it's time for
things to
close I know that it's time for things
to
[Music]
close well he'll end up in someone's
cabinet no no he won't no I wouldn't be
surprised if Donald Trump picks him you
think as a VP yes as a VP yes no yes yes
comment below I think it's possible way
to milk toast come on I I think he can
notice he hasn't attacked Tim Scott at
all yeah but he doesn't see him as a
threat well he went after Ben Carson
don't you remember how hard Donald yeah
but still but I mean they're they're
they're very similar you know they're
soft spoken black Republicans well
that's a part of it yes yes that is a
part of like remember Ben Carson tried
to stab his mother in the stomach folks
only was stopped by our belt buckle well
that's crazy he's a
psychopath I mean maybe he just say a
little distracted yeah this election
he's I don't know all right he's winning
by too much is that let's move on to New
York City is a Cess pool I have to say
City because New York state is also a
Cess pool doesn't get better city is
worse and uh if you remember I believe
it was Sergeant Daniel Penny remember
that situation in the subway wasn't
proof enough uh this latest Story shows
that New York City is not a place for a
Good Samaritan and you know like I've
said the left wants to turn violent
criminals into a new voting base and
they want to turn you the Law Abiding
Citizen into criminals that brings us to
the latest installment here of Empire of
[Music]
[Applause]
crime so this happened last week but he
was just uh arraigned uh and arrest
arrested and
arraigned arrested and arraigned yeah
arrested you're arrested first rain yeah
so that happened uh over this weekend
which is uh kind of an update to the
story for those of you who aren't
familiar with what what happened this
was last Monday a guy named John rot
witnessed a woman being robbed and these
facts by the way are not in question the
woman being robbed actually commented in
a way that is intensely disappointing
and I now believe John wrot should have
just done nothing uh this is at the 49th
Street subway station he saw it 49th
Street subway station by the way pretty
crowded area so this is some context
that people may miss there was a period
of time right you're talking about
Midtown that area you you wouldn't be
able to find a crime police were
basically responding to littering calls
so for this this is almost like going
back to the air of Jason Takes Manhattan
so he saw free Giuliani yes he saw a
woman being assaulted and he fired a
warning shot at the asent 43-year-old
John wrote In Handcuffs tonight LED away
from the Transit Police Station in the
subway police say he is the man they've
been looking for since yesterday who
allegedly tried to stop a mugging by
firing a gun inside a train station
police say a 49-year-old man known for
swiping people into the Subway and then
demanding cash was also trying to mug a
woman at the nrw station at 49th Street
in 7th Avenue that's when police say the
so-called Subway vigilante pulled out a
gun and fired into the air an action
officials say was not only illegal but
incredibly dangerous I just let you know
it also is Inc I don't know if you know
this was incredibly dangerous what's
that mugging a woman what yeah for her
not for the mug no not for the mugger I
mean unless somebody is standing by with
a gun yes exactly but that she says it
with such shock like fired a gun at a
subway station someone was potentially
being raped shouldn't that be kind of
the Shocker the prestige yeah but he he
fired it into the air they said like hey
bang straight up into the ceiling yeah
stop doing that yeah he should have
fired it right into the asal's ass
that's true it's dangerous you could
scare somebody masturbating exactly just
a hobo stops pissing hey whoa you scared
me bud you can't the pissing hobo is in
endangered species not in New York it's
not yeah man took it took me another
took me another 3 minutes to get it
going Hadad to get flow Max it was awful
you scared me I peed all over five
people you got some
money now he's got to get high
again to be so look and there this
brings some Dynamics here at play like
we've talked about uh in the past and
it's just this is not only New York it's
happening in large cities across the
country they want you all in large
cities so they can control you and they
can strip you of your First Amendment
Second Amendment writes this guy tried
to do the right thing these kinds of
incidents they're not all that uncommon
we had a close call yeah we did here at
the office actually uh this weekend that
was covered on local
news tell us how you saved the day well
you know there's a lot of Badness in the
world and you really just sometimes you
need to step up and protect what is
yours and defend it I have word that we
have security footage of the incident
we'd love for you to walk us through it
um that's that's not really necessary
you don't need to do that it'll be great
we have it right here Tom queue it up
please
don't so it seems you have nothing to do
with thwarted robbery
whatsoever well what you didn't hear on
that tape was that that robber made an
anti-semitic remark and my people have
been oppressed for over
five
all right so here's at the very
least uh some responses that are odd
yeah like I do I do want to and you can
comment below I want to live in a
society where I read more headlines
about men or women frankly shooting
would be as salance in the subway as
opposed to stories about rape or Rising
violent crime I you do have to you do
have to pick one right that's pretty
clear I mean I believe it was even a uh
uh Anna casparian was on with Patrick
Bet David talking about the crime in
California what a horrible job Gavin
Newsome has done once you grow up and
you reach a certain point you go okay I
get it the prison industrial complex but
it turns out if we just release violent
felons we are all the victims of more
violent crime so you would think that
there would at least be split opinion
from New York City officials but that's
not the case uh the New York City subway
president Richard Davey thought what uh
John wrote some people call him
vigilante some people call him a hero I
call him a hero okay hero yeah this is a
Subway president
he said that it was weird he s looks
very calm pulls out a gun fires Two
Shots calmly puts the gun back in a bag
and walks away I mean it is weird but
the point is is you know that's not what
we need anybody system strange things
are happening to me I get raped on the
subway thanks Randy new man strange ra
Str you got a victim
me it seems like I got the
HIV cuz you were busy raping
meop strange strange things I think this
headline from Bloomberg is weird it says
New York subways have less crime but
more violence what how is
that violence isn't crime yeah did
somebody fact check this I mean they
mean lower overall crime because you
don't actually site but but more vience
there's always less crime when you're
not arresting people for crimes exactly
you didn't you didn't get the stats or
but what's surprising is that there's
more violence and they're also not
arresting people for violence well the
ambulance comes yes exactly eventually
Eric Adams you know him um um um brown
turtle he thinks that this looks meaning
the man actually doing something and I
say this because you need to understand
no one is coming to save you if you are
in New York it is going to get worse and
the people in power are going to ensure
that it gets worse you the the
law-abiding citizen they are desperate
to frame you as a criminal and they are
desperate to show empathy for the
criminal so they can gain some votes so
they can gain and Uncle Sam's none the
wiser so Eric Adams uh thinks that this
could look too much like one of my
favorite films death wish this is not a
Charles Bronson area you know with Death
Wish let the police do their job uh
don't think that you can do that job
without the proper training that comes
from law enforcement hey you black
turtle
Punk
is that any way to treat a hero of the
subway well you heard his new policy
Eric Adam's new policy in New York uh
see say see something do nothing say
nothing move on ignore it keep walking I
think that new policy is see something
get
raped so as for the uh would be victim
John wrote protected because no good
deed goes unpunished by the subway
president the mayor and even the person
and you are protecting she wishes that
he didn't use a gun this is a quote
where she says yes I do think he is a
hero but I don't know I would likely
think him a bigger hero if if he tried
to help me without a
gun did you see John wrote did you see
The Man Without a Gun he doesn't have a
snowballs chance in hell hold on pull
that pull that quote back up hold on we
we didn't read the best part in my eyes
this is the continuation in my eyes the
gun is a little extreme it was a very
dangerous situation anything could have
happened yeah
the point lady what is you no excuse me
mugger stay right here don't you fire
that gun at the ceiling you continue
what you were doing and rob me this is
too dangerous just walks up the mugger
slaps him she's like oh you're going to
penetrate me now aren't you anything
could have happened everyone in New
York's all mad cuz we're messing with
their culture I know how dare you stop a
mugging this is New York City yes you
get what you deserve I'm sorry at this
point you get what you deserve well let
me give you some stats here as far as
New Yorkers uh in the subway uh January
to aug August of 2023 burglaries in the
subway are up
150% uh not bad ridership overall is
only 70% of the prepandemic levels which
means people must really hate it because
it's impossible to get around that City
without using the subway wait a minute
the numbers up in ridership is down yeah
the crime is up in ridership is down
yeah fewer people to commit the crimes
in and only 15% of New Yorkers feel very
safe riding the subway yeah who are the
15% that's a lower percentage than of
Muslims globally who believe that
violence is Justified against
non-muslims that's true 15% is just the
people that are making the crimes yeah
no that's feel they don't they don't
ride the subway they're like oh I've
heard of it uh New York City the
assaults are up 60% over the last 13
years look here's where we are New York
there's Subway it's it's it's dangerous
and officials want to make sure that you
don't get any ideas about protecting
yourself so they want to ensure that you
remain completely uh well exposed let's
be honest hey you need big brother to
come in and help you if you're not able
to protect yourself and this is the
funny thing is people are obviously they
armed to the teeth in rural Ral areas
and the argument that the left always
makes is well you think you know in the
city that' be a real problem no no in
the city it's a real problem that you're
not allowed to protect yourself you you
know you don't need to protect yourself
against two-legged Predators so much
when you're out in the middle of nowhere
when you're out in your own Farm you
need to protect yourself from wild
animals out here you need some some good
snake shot here in Texas these are the
conditions right now what you are seeing
in New York City that's where you get a
Bernie gets if you look at what happened
with dirty hary death wish that was a
response to the soft on crime policies
where Americans felt helpless yeah
that's what happened in the 70s and the
80s where the Vigilante film was born
you are going to see that you are going
to see more Vigilantes this guy is not a
vigilante no this is a guy who stopped
something he stopped an act that was
taking place what I mean is you are
going to have more people seeking out
criminals to shoot those kinds of
Vigilantes I guarantee it you can call
me on it especially in the big cities
where they're not doing their job in the
first place right we've talked about the
reism rates we've talked about how
there's a Turn Style like 500 I think
either robberies or crimes were
committed by like four guys or something
like that they were rested 500 times I
think just just really small group of
people but we do also I don't know if
this is going to be funny or not we'll
see the a picture of the Asal ah
looks like a nice fell looks like an ad
for meth
classic those are deep set wrinkles got
too much time on your hands he's got
sensitive ears you can't fire that gun
in a Subway him come on yeah he's 26
yeah that guy's
26 it's Adam 26 yeah
since and you
know 22 oh 26 he was just trying to give
you that se sex with his wife yeah just
my wife we were trying to do some stuff
I was mistaking her for my wife yeah and
so I started treating her like a bag of
crap because that's what I do with my
wife it was an audition you know what we
call a cattle
call and this is the problem with
feminism yes I said it the woman was
being assaulted and she's more upset
that he used a gun and those are the
people people who are determining the
policies in your city that is the
problem the there's no logic to that
it's well I just wish he didn't use a
gun oh because you think guns are mean
and
scary I'd prefer you just say thank you
and go on your way I'm curious to know
how who what side she's on in the Hamas
story yeah one guess oh I would have
preferred he didn't use a gun but glad
Hamas did you know yes I'm sorry like I
you know they shouldn't have kidnapped
people but do you have to kill so many
of them well apparently not enough yet
so
yeah violence is aoral you've heard me
say this many times violence is aoral I
can use a gun to rape a woman or I can
use a gun to stop a rape and get
arrested yeah I can same thing with
money I can use money to go purchase
fentel or I can use money to uh fund a
homeless
shelter that's assuming that you believe
homeless shelters are actually doing
anything true because most of the money
gets funel to the people who run it and
they drive Mercedes to and front but
they do it the back door so you don't
see it that's been this week's new New
York state of
[Music]
[Applause]
crime sorry Empire State of crime now I
warn you um with this next story we
always tell you this is a PG-13 plus uh
but uh it it is disturbing we're not
going to be showing you any videos of of
of people dying just to be clear but the
the the subject matter is disturbing and
it ties into the idea of criminals not
being treated as the criminals they are
uh you see it with Hamas you saw it with
the manifesto by the way thank you so
much to everyone who supported uh the
work last week the Nashville Manifesto
you are the reason it was the number one
story of the week I mean could it could
be one of the biggest uh reveals
honestly this year not and I'm not
taking credit these are the people who
work here in our undercover unit you
want more like that please do consider
uh joining lightos credit.com mugclub
and uh you get twice the show every day
Friday show Alex Jones Nick depalo every
day you get the Hodge twins you get
Brian K gun guns and gear but you also
fund the undercover journalism uh and
the tip lines that we have we have some
some lines out there right now that are
we have to do our due diligence we aim
once we aim right but we'll shock you uh
and this is the overall point you see
that with the subway uh shooter there um
you see it sorry with the vigilante hero
the attacker you get the point now we
get to this story in Las Vegas the left
will cover
crimes very differently simply depending
on the asant it has to fit in with a
narrative or it gets ignored like you
saw with the Nashville Manifesto that
was memory hold really really quickly um
or it gets misrepresented so this just
happened in Las Vegas late last week a
white teenager Jonathan Lewis was beaten
to death by 15 black students and I say
that because it matters and because if
you were watching this on any of the
mainstream Outlets or even your local
news that by the way is run by three
major corporations you would wouldn't
know this white teenager Jonathan Lewis
beaten to death by 15 black students at
a Las Vegas High School a teen severely
beaten by more than a dozen students has
died in the hospital after several days
on life support now again to provide
some context here so people don't just
say well okay what was he doing could he
be a white supremacist let me read you a
a quick uh this is from news8 local news
November 1st over 15 juveniles brutally
attacked 17-year-old Jonathan Lewis near
Rancho High School after he sought to
defend a younger friend who had been
robbed by the group this group already
committed a crime robbed a younger
friend and he went to them saying hey
can you can you give it back can you
give it back at which point the group of
entirely black teenagers 15 of them beat
him to death here is a video again uh I
warn you you're not seeing anything
super graphic but just the idea of it
should should disturb your soul here's a
video of the beating taking place
[Music]
partially that that's enough you guys
can find most of it on there and again
what matters with
this people say well how do you know
that's true when you talk about Israel
Hamas well we're using the Hamas videos
right they want you to circulate them
they're proud of killing innocent people
yeah these videos are being T the are
not being taken by people who are trying
to stop an attack no these are being
taken by people who are hoping to get
social media Cloud they want this video
out there teenagers these bullies not
they want to gain notoriety just to be
clear now here is the media's coverage
of the story see if you can spot what's
omitted Metro says about 15 kids were
involved in a fight that has left one
student hospitalized with critical
injuries a teenager is fighting for his
life after being beaten by 15 other kids
near Rancho High School Metro officers
responding to reports of a student fight
across the street from Rancho High
School the investigation revealing the
victim got into a physical altercation
with 15 people before cops arrived now
from the family of Jonathan Lewis a
Rancho High School student who has died
after a severe attack by 15 other
students last week near the school and
what really bothers me is that female
reporter saying a physical altercation
no no an innocent man was beaten to
death yeah a couple of them said fight
yeah that's not a fight he was beaten to
death he was beaten to death by Jackal
who felt enabled to do so because they
would get off consequent free
consequence free at worst have to go to
a high school guidance counselor and
tell them about how they never hugged
enough let me read you some media
headlines here Las Vegas teen beaten to
death by mob of attackers outside of
high school teen beaten near high school
has died from injuries father says Vegas
teen beaten to death by mob of 15
bullies outside high school after
standing up for smaller friend nowhere
nowhere is race mentioned in these
stories imagine if we were and this
isn't just
whataboutism imagine if you had the
inverse yeah imagine if it was 15 white
guys who beat up one black I don't know
that you can find that at a school in
the United States in the last 15 years I
really
don't I I I I genuinely don't and there
are many many stories to this effect
yeah and this is not to be clear not
pulling a Nick Cannon and saying it's
because of the melanin in your skin it
is because not only of a culture but in
an and I don't just mean the culture you
know hip-hop culture what a lot of young
black boys who are often fatherless look
up to as an example but because of white
culture of saying we need to stand down
and check our privilege where we to
behavior that would be tolerated nowhere
else nowhere else would people run
interference for this and we'll get to
the overall crime stats that show this
is a common occurrence right now in the
United States particularly in schools
yeah well and it's the glorification of
this kind of behavior and no
accountability for anybody involved that
really is the problem like you said they
want this out there they want to take
video of this and say look see how cool
we are these people need to be going to
jail yes I'm sorry you just killed
somebody they need to be tried as adults
yes yeah I mean you just I mean there
was there was video there that we again
we're not going to get too far into that
because we don't want to show everybody
but stomping on somebody's head against
the pavement as four five six other
people just in that one second are also
kicking and others waiting to come into
the wings to see if they can jump in on
the act like what we what are we doing
here yeah it does sound like yeah what
kind of people are we raising in society
and what kind of accountability is
culture whether it's Black Culture white
culture American whatever what kind of
accountability are we saying is
appropriate here because the media just
went out there and said oh this was a
tussle no the guy got jumped because he
was trying to defend his there was a
little bit of a dust up between Lyle
Skirmish between Lyall and Chris a group
of Jackal decided to kill another person
maybe that's a little closer I don't
know maybe Workshop it see if you can
come up with something but something a
little bit more along those lines would
be more accurate these kinds of
activities for example The Knockout game
they used to only take place with gang
initi initiations which were incredibly
rare for the worst of the worst among
Society now these are just mainstream
games like they're memes like planking
but hit hit like hit the like button
right now it helps with the algorithm
but if you automatically assume the race
of the perpetrator when it's never
mentioned if you read a story like this
and you see no mention of the race don't
you make some assumptions now let's be
honest that's the problem that's the
rebound effect you are creating a
generation of people who are going to be
more racist or at the very least more
suspicious when you raise an entire
generation of people who feel guilty for
something they cannot control checking
their privilege look someone sometimes
we get Guff people go oh uh you know
Crowder is a cuck he he said he's not
proud to be white I'm I'm not just like
I'm not ashamed to be white it's I have
no control over it whatsoever it's it's
it's something that doesn't really
matter to me I never sit there and go
thank oh man look at my look at my white
skin I'm really proud of the fact that I
have white skin but I'm not going to
look at it and say oh my gosh I need to
go to the soup kitchen for extra hours
because I need to check my privilege
it's it could not be less relevant this
is not the first time this has happened
let me read you some other crimes where
the race was omitted when the per was
black uh right here you have one you
have Ethan lying offered broken
skullbone in Brawl outside LeBron LeBron
james' I promise School the perks were
three black men oh whoops I guess LeBron
James isn't as great of a professor as
we we we had hoped for yeah basketball
celebrity schools LeBron James School
whatever Barry Manalo had one all
right it was yeah it was a school for
the SE for the closeted homosexuals all
right really yeah the jawless closeted
homosexuals I'm just saying all
celebrities have these we school now
here's another one teen girl allegedly
slugs Asian woman attacks witness inoss
hate crime on NYC Subway okay the per
was of course a black teen girl and she
didn't allegedly slug an Asian woman she
did and then she attacked a witness
here's another one woman spits on subway
Rider in suspected anti-asian hate crime
in Park Slope hey guess what the per of
course in this instance was a black
woman this has been happening across the
country uh really since we've had the
soft on crime
what oh I don't know why he's why are
you here is this why do we have M Gibson
head you get raped by a pack of it'll be
your fault hey who Mel that's the that's
the overreaction that we're talking
about the pendulum swings too far the
other way and then you end up with Mel
Gibson head you do end up with Mel
Gibson head really quickly they listed
the the the Asian person in the last two
examples and didn't listen the list the
perpetrator because they were pushing
this anti Asian hate thing right where
they're trying to say like hey Asian
Community we're standing with you unless
of course you're trying to get into
Harvard they we're not really standing
with you so much and make it seem like
white people were the problem why is it
possible that that we can live in a
country where you can't just call it out
across the board we covered this with
the Nashville thing they called it out
immediately when it was anti-black
crimes right when somebody's shooting up
a store because they're racist and I
understand that do it but when it's the
other way around remember when we were
live Fort Worth the shooting it was like
catnip and then it turns out it was a
black kid and he just came in and he was
a bully and we didn't really have they
like ah you don't know anything about
this they're like we'll give you more
information later by the way back to
Donald Trump yes back back to Donald
Trump who's who's orange said Eminem oh
what a what a cipher yeah orange orange
yeah wusha it was it's an SUV it's not
even a person yeah exactly it's true
it's not even they not even list the
color of the SUV right they don't always
miss the race though no they don't
always list here's the thing if they
miss if they never listed the race ever
fine but they do it all the time when
it's a white perpetrator yes exactly
right here let's read these are from
people
NPR white teen allegedly tried to drown
black child in racially charged attack
three white men are found guilty of
murder in the killing of Ahad Aubrey
white man will stand trial for shooting
black team black teen Ralph yl who went
to wrong house judge rules but now we
have some examples of the selective uh I
don't even want to say selective just
lies these are just dishonest the way
when someone crafts a headline
deliberately omitting information to
mislead you it's a lie and here's how we
confirm thisly let's look at some of the
crime statistics the FBI 2022 violent
crime stats black Americans make up
13.6% of the population and
43% of the violent crimes the victims of
violent crimes 57% of them are white in
San Francisco and here's it's really
hard because if you actually look at the
FBI the doj the CDC at one point in time
they stopped recording once they
realized that politically it was it was
tough for them uh they stopped recording
the racial gap between crime so you
could find out the perpetrator of a
crime the race of the perpetrator and
you could find out in some instances the
uh race of the victim of a crime but you
couldn't find out if the racial uh
makeup of the perpetrator was different
from the victim so you couldn't find out
who committed what crime which crime de
see who was the victim at the hands of
which race we used to have those stats I
believe it was 2014 2016 when they
stopped recording them so I acknowledge
that because this one comes from a small
sample size sample size where they did
conduct this study in San fr Francisco
85% of all assault crimes in the Bay
Area were black against Asian 85% of all
assault crimes we black against Asian
small sample size but that's because
nationally your government looking out
for you doesn't let you know who commits
crimes and who the victims are but you
can make an inference right if 57% of
the victims are white and 43% of the
perpetrators are black who only make up
12% of the population hey you saw crash
though so you don't want you don't want
to be racist you don't want to be racist
if you're let's say in New York City
were a violent offender who is
statistically more likely to be black
committing a crime against an Asian
person or a white person you don't want
to be racist so you should walk right in
as a completely helpless victim because
you can't defend yourself with a firearm
then you'll be excoriated by the mayor
by the uh New York City subway president
and potentially white women around you
if you do anything yeah you are now less
safe but the good news is Cash bail and
recidivism is up exponentially no cash
bill you don't even have to have it oh
sorry I said said cash
I mean no cash no cash right yeah you
don't need any cash it's just I want to
go do you have anything to put down no
no I do not oh sorry yeah go ahead so so
let me just do I do I understand this
correctly me as a white man right in in
blonde hair blueeyed I'm not in a lot of
ways um if I see a black man committing
a crime I need to kind of like in the
old days is there a doctor in the house
I have to go is there a black man
willing to step in and stop this but
otherwise it's racist I wouldn't say
that because the black guy is going to
think that you're being a smartass and
beat you harder oh yeah especially if
you do it in that day Chelle white guy
voice is there a black man who's willing
to help me is this getting
smart with me beat him harder no man I
beat his white ass brother I said is
there a black man in the house that can
help me oh my Lord I don't even have a
gun I'm G to go find that just so I
can use it on you that's a that's a
fling and I will say this I've talked
about this on the show we do black and
white and the gray issues uh where I
just talk with you'd be surprised as to
how much you have in common but that's
it's usually in areas where there's a
mix of white and black people and
they've learned to live together when
you have people who who Silo themselves
uh into a culture that they view as
exclusively black culture and the other
white people that's where you end up
with gangs of
15 15 beating a a white boy to death
laughing think about that 15 black kids
not one of them had a conscience this is
not normal you will say violence has
gone on in this country for decades sure
but that type of
collective
uh just just assault with a total lack
of humanity is not something that has
historically existed in this country
this was not the norm if you want to say
hey school shootings are up when or mass
shootings are up when statistically
that's not necessarily true these kinds
of interracial gang assaults are up
people know it people see it they're
living it and you want them to not
believe their lying eyes and ears and it
always depends on if the criminal is
convenient that's what you saw with
Nashville
that's why we released the manifesto
that we had and that's why if you want
to see more of that look we always we I
I'm biased I try and be very
straightforward but we're not going to
lie to you all the references are
available and if you want to join mug
Club you know where to go lith
credit.com mugclub okay we're going to
continue do you have something you
wanted yeah well I just wanted to think
our sponsor Walther right so you've said
this many times you know if you're going
to go out there and you're going to buy
a firearm and look if this guy had had a
firearm maybe he could have defended
himself but just try well it's a kid at
school well no no no he was across the
street from school and maybe if there
was a parent that could a parent with a
firearm just saying hey hey hey hey you
know maybe don't beat this kid by the
way they're a sponsor they've been a
sponsor for the show for a very long
time uh they have the balls to sponsor
the show just here's what it is go to
walfer arms.com and find a dealer near
you often gun ranges will let you try
the firearm I'm not going to trash there
are plenty of good guns out there yeah
at a certain point it's like do you like
BMW do you like Mercedes do you like
Tesla I don't know someone's going to
crap all over that uh but if you type in
a review Walther PDP is our new gun
review Walther PPQ review just type it
in you will see that everyone says yeah
this is the best kept secret in the in
the gun industry because they don't have
massive advertising campaigns try the
Walther guarantee you you'll buy it
that's it they're they're cool they're
fun they're deadly they sell themselves
all right like it it's like blasting
caps
now Sunday night I don't know blasting
caps uh John Oliver you a big fan John I
think he's funny yeah he can be funny he
can be let me put it that way he doesn't
stick The Landing always he's a cheeky
bastard he is he is he's a funny guy I
do think he's funny um he's also wrong
so a lot you can be both yes you can be
funny you can be wrong uh Sunday night
John Oliver and we haven't done one of
these rebuttal Point by point in a while
but every now and then you get someone
who volunteers as tribute to just
encapsulate all of the moronic
arguments that you've heard across the
web asphere where you're like oh okay he
he basically went to his writers that
day and said hey how can I give louder
with Crowder a
layup he decided to take on the Israel
Hamas conflict imploring his audience
off the bat to see the humanity on both
sides which is
nice I know that for many Israelis there
is an understandable sense of fear and
precarity right now amid the Spectre of
Hamas attacks and Rockets flying
overhead but it's worth also
acknowledging the overwhelming sense of
precarity among Palestinians living
under a blockade and a barrage of
Israeli rockets and it has to be
possible to feel the pain in one
Community without denying it in another
it has to be that is perhaps the most
necessary precondition for peace because
real peace here will clearly be
difficult it it's going to be struggled
toward as part of a larger pursuit of
Justice which will in turn require an
honest and uncomfortable Reckoning with
all the decisions that brought us to
this point and I know that hope is
scarce right now all right yeah Gerald
I'm sorry he just he left one thing out
when he's saying they they have a
problem with the Rockets being fired at
them from Israel what about the Hamas
murders of you know their own citizens
and keeping them from running and
fleeing South as Israel said you just
need to make sure that you include in
their precarity as you said the fact
that their own people that they elected
are killing them as well don't blame
Israel for all of it yeah that's a good
point and to be fair look and I want to
uh you know full transparency here he
does try and Lead this by saying that
hey Hamas doesn't represent all the
Palestinians so we need to differentiate
and he says that you know just like
Netanyahu doesn't represent all Israelis
that part okay so that part is true and
he kind of starts it off trying to both
sides it uh but often when you see that
it means I'm about to
lie because if you look at his time
spent in his segment we timed it out
criticizing Israel uh about 20 minutes
uhuh time criticizing not just not just
we're not talking about Palestine but
Hamas 6 minutes so at the very least you
were going to say okay you were say time
criticizing the Palestinian people who
are not Hamas all right that's very low
and then the time criticizing Israel
okay that and then the time criticizing
actual Hamas should be highest no time
critici criticizing all of Israel 20
minutes Hamas six minutes they weren't
evenhanded pause this right now and and
I want you to comment what predictions
do you have for the claims that Oliver
is going to make if you're not watching
this live if you're listening on audio
just hit pause don't
cheat because we're about to go through
them and whatever it is you're thinking
in your mind probably yes you called
it spoiler all right so let's go to uh
we'll do a claim truth format a claim
from John Oliver that Hamas does not
represent uh the people of Gaza this
senior Hamas official
uh gazi hammad recently doubled down on
the massacre of October 7th by saying we
must teach Israel a lesson and we will
do it twice and three times and for many
commentators all the citizens of Gaza
are implicated in that sort of rhetoric
thanks to one key fact that you hear all
the time is it it's twice three times
does he mean does he mean 2.3 does it
mean five times like two plus three I
really don't know twice three times two
times three times a terrorist I don't
know
here's the truth
they don't represent all Palestinians
but Hamas represents a lot of
Palestinians in January 2006 Hamas won
74 out of 132 seats the Middle East
quartet called these free fair and
secure elections where have I heard that
before yeah I know well no no no those
were free and fair ours are the freest
and fairest because we're better yes
okay there we go because well we're not
better we don't be ethnocentric but you
know we're we're we're doing okay is
we're doing all right we're more
advanced July 2023 relatively recent 57%
of gazin viewed Hamas favorably ah
October 7th 2023 here we also see it's
not just Hamas that we're discussing so
you can say that they don't represent
all of the Palestinian people but you
have not seen an election with 57% of
the vote in this country in decades and
then you also look at this footage where
you see gazin civilians nons soldiers
not Hamas gleefully participating in
Terror attacks against Israeli people
[Music]
why is he beeping I keeps hitting the
wrong button move fence
[Applause]
move oh yeah they all look like
soldiers these are hostages seen in
pickup trucks being driven through
Gaza I don't see a l of Civilian
protesters demanding
[Music]
Humanity just stealing their
stuff unbelievable so again it doesn't
represent every single person who lives
in Palestine but it represents enough
yeah by the way uh when's the last time
they had an election in uh in Gaza oh
yeah that's right 2006 when Hamas came
to power they just kind of kept it
they're the dictators the world hasn't
called them that though they just they
just either way you need to get them out
of power yeah yeah yeah the people if if
anything if you want to help the people
of Gaza if you're saying they don't
represent the people of Gaza then you
should want Hamas to be obliterated yep
you only did a fair election once that's
true yes said Vladimir Putin the
sequel's Never As Good no you got to
just one and done like what is this a
leprechaun franchise then we're going
doing elections in space it's elections
the hood his name is basically his name
is gazi hammad it's basically Gaza Hamas
I
know like no one else is noticing that
like his name is Gaza Hamas well the
next election he'll change it to Lil
gazi
oh so here's another claim I want to
hear that mixtape though I do cousin
little Ben got it'll be fired it'll all
be about killing Jews let's be honest
that is going to be the hook for him
they just he has a one track mind that
Kanye
yes here's another claim that he makes
claim number two uh from John Oliver
that Hamas was actually moderate when
they were elected and we need to split
this clip into two remember tul man all
right let's watch this hi Hamas went out
of its way to present itself as more
moderate back then in fact here is that
same Hamas official who recently
Justified the October 7th attacks
shortly before that 2006 election we are
a moderate organization really we're not
radical organization and we are not
extremist or fundamentalist no we are
organization speaking believe in
democracy and the freedom and political
pluralization yeah Hamas really tried to
Rebrand it now look I get the here's the
truth okay even though he tries to say
see that that same guy who he represent
you just you just said that they lie
about everything they can't be trusted
as it relates to anything period that's
the same guy who said that Hamas would
repeat the October 7th attacks in case
you missed it this was like 45 seconds
ago this senior Hamas official uh gazi
hammad recently doubled down on the
massacre of October 7th by saying we
must teach Israel a lesson and we will
do it twice and three times remember we
made that I had the whole quip about is
it is it two times is it five times yeah
it's the same guy it's the same guy and
I know he acknowledges that it's the
same guy God what are you doing he's
acting like he's trying to cut it off at
the past but but that's the guy when the
guy is the liar so let's play the rest
of his clip because then he tries to he
tries to say well yeah but that's now
but they initially actually presented
themselves as moderate which of course
is not true but let's hear him make the
argument well that was he play the whole
thing did I play the whole thing all
right okay that the whole thing I don't
know I don't know maybe it is
that way we split it and run through all
right and here's the truth well split
would mean there's two of them yeah well
or three all right fine H whatever his
name is Hamas has clearly always been
radical you know how John Oliver just
showed you that he was lying yeah well
it's not that hard to fact check that
the guy's
lying because in the 1988 founding
Charter from Hamas it says Israel will
exist and will continue to exist until
is Islam will obliterate it just as it
obliterated others before it the
movement is but one Squadron that should
be supported by more and more squadrons
from this vast Arab and Islamic World
until the enemy is vanquished and
Allah's Victory is realized that was
their founding Charter you have the guy
who he quotes as having been moderate
saying they're going to destroy Israel
and the Jewish people let's give you
some more examples all references
available at L with.com I wish I didn't
have to do this but apparently I do 2005
Hamas spokesperson mushir al- masle I
want to make sure I get that right but
let me get it a little bit wrong so it
pisses him
off this was him prior to the gazin
election saying we have we have come
here in multitudes to Proclaim that H
and Ashan will be taken by the mujahadin
we have come here to say that the
weapons of the resistance that you will
see here remain Allah willing so that we
can liberate Palestine all of Palestine
from sea to the river whether they like
it or not that is exactly what they say
right
there I don't know what seriously it's I
just read it I just read the the thing
you should just smile and blow me
cuz I deserve it get
him he's having a rough day that last
part is really interesting from The
River To The Sea what the No No No but
hold on this is this is a benign chant
it's a benign chant from The River To
The Sea Palestine will be it's just
protesters who are just making sure that
the humanitarian Situation's addressed
does it rhyme in uh does it rhyme in
Arabic I don't know but they had to flip
it cuz it says from you know sea to the
river but the river to the sea from the
sea to the river we will make them
quiver it just doesn't
roll that's just what they have now at
these protests in college like from
River to the sea from sea to shining
dead juy yeah that's what they're saying
from sea to River means all of it that's
why he says all of pal that means
there's no place for
Jews that's what he's saying
Annihilation it's in their Charter I
hope I've crystallized it for you before
they even set up the the the way to
manage the country literally right off
the top it's like hey are you going to
put to like president vice president no
no no no no no Gil Jews first like what
hold on but you haven't done anything
Kamas well it's this radical it's this
radical new strategy it's called Jew
death therapy
Bob they have a very uh interesting way
of speaking Yeah like terrorists yes
like terrorists where you think that
they're going one way and they're not
they they totally AG at the end cuz he
goes uh Israel will be Israel will exist
until we destroy
them you will be a virgin until I rape
you relax kind of buried the lead there
Hamas the Jews are perfectly safe until
I tie my
[Laughter]
shoe oh o o Ox
dead so there you go Hamas was moderate
the guy he quotes clearly says he wants
to eradicate all Jews we just gave you
some more examp now I don't and I also
by the way not one dead American Soldier
just to be correct correct I think that
but morally Israel has to wipe out Hamas
and we're going to get to the stupid
ceasefire pardon my language
but this is just the people from
intelligencia they have to this is why
they they get their dick tied in a
pretzel because they cannot this is how
you end up with gays for Palestine and
you end up with people like John Oliver
who claimed to be against hate speech so
they find it more of an affront to the
sensibilities that a man in New York
stopping the assault of a woman with his
firearm by shooting it into the air
that's more offensive to them than a
government who in their very Charter 88
and then reiterated in 2006 all the way
up until and including today every
single day wants the eradication or
obliteration of all Jews it's not a
tenable position and they say well this
these these are the people the
intellectuals the Nom chamski of the
world this is what they believe it's
because they're just chasing some of
virtue signal and sound smarter than you
rather than teach you and they end up
with a position that is entirely
inconsistent there is no way to be a
modern liberal and hold these positions
that they do as a matter of policy not
at all you know at least I respect for
example Hamas and that they're
consistent like they're not like on the
one hand I hate Jews but on the other
hand I want to kill all of them you're
like well those two go
together I think you're wrong that's
great news yeah but the lip is like on
the one hand I believe that girls who
are 6 years old should be able to go
through gender transition on the other
hand I think that Hamas has it mostly
right so let's go through another claim
from John Oliver and this is the Again
The Selective editing what they choose
to not cover just like the racial crimes
earlier where he makes the claim that
Israel is deliberately targeting
civilians in just the first six days of
the war it dropped 6,000 bombs on a
strip of land just 25 mil long and at
most 7 m wide that is nearly as many as
the record number that the US dropped on
Afghanistan in a single year as of this
taping more than 11,000 people had been
killed including at least 4,000 children
Hamas numb all Palestinians in Gaza did
support Hamas which they do not the
Relentless bombings of civilians there
would still be abhorrent Collective
punishment is a war crime okay so here's
the truth all right now that number is's
quoting Hamas numbers just to be clear
the Palestinian Authority those numbers
are being that's propaganda now I'm not
saying that a lot of people haven't been
killed but the numbers he is citing are
from Hamas while he's saying that the
Israelis right the IDF are dishonest and
that they are targeting same homas said
a hospital was bombed and turned out
that the parking lot and some cars got
frecked or 600 killed anyone who's
citing those numbers by the way 10,000
11,000 people killed 4,000 children they
are citing Hamas as their reference
which I would just say is slightly I
would say that Hamas as a reference is
biased if not slightly questionable a
little bit that's just my opinion man so
Hamas also if we were to say okay 10,000
people killed 11 whatever they try and
claim now well hold on a second let's
just say the number is higher than the
1200 uh you know innocent Jews who were
killed on October 7th by the way notice
Israel revises their numbers they had it
at 1400 they revised it to lower you
will never see that from Hamas but let's
say the number is higher okay but do I
care if those people are bloodthirsty
terrorists that matters right now what
also matters is even if the civilian
death toll let's say is higher for the
people of uh Gaza than in Israel well
could that be because Hamas
intentionally hides behind civilians
without fail it is a matter of strategy
for them places like hospitals places
like refugee camps places like schools
and before you say this is Jewish
propaganda don't worry I have some third
party sources this is just right on the
ground you see some bombs weapons in a
kindergarten it's a good place to have
them you teach the kids how to use
them that's what they do that's like
metal shop it's
[Music]
different weird showing
yeah it's take your daddy terrorist
to school
day before you said Jewish propaganda in
2014 Al jazer reported that Hamas had
built the tunnel Network under the uh
under the jabalia refugee camp okay you
that that's overlay 12 there Matt you
can bring that up gaza's internal tunnel
network is reportedly even more complex
than cross border routes and involves
multiple branches that run under refugee
camps in uh in conun uh J baa I hope I'm
pronouncing it right sh all other
densely populated areas these hide
weaponry and are designed for Hamas
leadership to remain protected and
mobile and here's the thing so you have
that Jewish Soldier showing it to you
right there or um someone who you would
just say is a propagandist you know or
rat to people who support Hamas now you
have Al jazer who of course would rather
uh portray um the Palestinian people in
Hamas in a more favorable light
certainly compared to the IDF but let's
go straight to the horse's mouth Hamas
themselves have even admitted and taken
credit for these tactics in
interviews
ah see that last part he says yes yes we
have tunnels because we are avoiding for
people listening on audio because we're
trying to avoid the airplanes who are
trying to kill us now it's confirmed
through Al daer and other sources that
these tunnels go under schools these
tunnels go under refugee camps and he
says well everyone knows that God's a
75% refugees it's not our job to protect
them with our tunnels it's it's the job
yes it's the United Nations job to come
in and protect these people and I just
want to be clear we're talking about the
same places that Israel has had gone
through Great Links to make sure that
all the civilians can flee these areas
before bombing they dropped leaflets
they did everything that they could
short of smoke signals to let you know
hey tomorrow at 5: we're bombing this
place because Hamas uses it and they
have tunnels underground get out of here
and then Hamas doesn't let people leave
this is just the IDF is actually
escorting them out too and a lot of yes
there's video of that video of Tanks of
Israeli tanks escorting people in
Palestine out of these areas at a Gaza
Strip out of these areas can you you
can't make the argument right and even
if you say oh I hate Israel okay okay
but John Oliver is a liar let's just be
clear about that I'm not going to say
he's being he's being um misleading John
Oliver is a liar with this segment John
Oliver knows that he's using hamas's
numbers John Oliver knows that Hamas
uses people as human Shields he knows
that he knows that and he's saying the
opposite so let's go to another claim
from our favorite immigrant who uh makes
his bank here in the United States says
that Israel was already uh destroying
Gaza and this is just asinine before
this current conflict Palestinians have
been on the receiving end of that
extremism twice over subject to the
inadequacies and and cruelties of a
Hamas government and the punishing
isolation and daily misery of an Israeli
one because Israel's approach to Gaza
has been truly punishing fencing people
in limiting exits and trapping them
inside of what has been called an open a
prison by many human rights
organizations life under a blockade
there has been hard for a long time even
when there aren't bombs flying but by
the way he says their response has been
punishing as opposed to when 1,200
innocent people are tortured kidnapped
and killed your response should not be
punishing yeah I mean let's Also let's
not lose scope of this for a second like
it should be punishment by the way I
even address this when we talk about
prisons here in the United States I
think Rehabilitation matters I think
punish
punishment should still be a part of the
equation I still think that prison
should be uncomfortable it shouldn't be
like a Swedish prison where it's an Ikea
display yeah with the PS5 yeah no they
actually do I know and in GMO GMO they I
remember back then they had the new I
think it was the Xbox 360 really yeah I
remember go I visited them and then I
wasn't able to show all the footage so
here's the truth you play Modern Warfare
As
Americans they get to be on the good
side for why would I want to play myself
it's called acting
I want to expand my
range guard come here I have to pee on
you
e he sets a timer two guard get over
here oh the guards time for a
cocktail so the
truth is that Israel instituted the
blockade to stop weapons from coming in
right they they seize weapons IEDs RPGs
let's also be clear the blockade has
been upheld by who who who Egypt let me
read you a quote I thought you were to
say Mike Jones keeping a moss out of the
Sinai Peninsula has been an imperative
for the Egyptian government since at
least 2007 let me give you another truth
here as John Oliver tries to paint this
as this rag tag group of Misfits Gaza
gets tons tons of foreign aid help
largely money funding the Gaza over the
last
decade un 4.5 billion Qatar where clock
boy decided to go for a while 1.3
billion Egypt 500 million Germany 80
million the United States since 2021
alone 400 million that's the amount of
money that has been sent to Gaza over
the last decade also Israel has granted
over 18,000 work permits to gazans to
work in Israel and I get and I'm not
saying it's perfect just to be clear I
understand there's no easy way out of
this if there people there who are ruled
by Hamas who constantly bombard them
with propaganda while they also abuse
their own citizens but you tell me if
this looks exactly like an open air
prison as the leftist humanitarian
organizations want you to
believe it's like a reason to
[Music]
work like Club Med with terrorists
yeah
awesome quick
trip I thought there's no way that this
was
[Music]
true to
prison well it is now I'm sure we're
seeing the nicer Parts I'm sure we're
seeing the nicer parts of Gaza don't get
me wrong I'm not saying that it actually
is like sandals
but we don't put tourism commercials
with pictures of Detroit right no
exactly yeah actually they do in
Michigan Pure Michigan they tell yeah
they actually did tell people to go
visit Detroit and then there was just an
epidemic of hipster rapings in Detroit
so oh cool yeah yeah exactly sick it did
job well
done good job Michigan the point is you
can't only present one side here it's
it's an open air prison it's let's also
be clear about the fact fact that Israel
hasn't they withdrew yeah from before
hamas's Fair election yes well this is
this is my point John Oliver makes the
point and I'm not quote it's kind of a
loose quote most people don't support
Hamas right not all Palestinians okay
Uprising because Hamas is controlling
you and apparently they're doing such a
bang up job that you guys are living in
an open air prison uh even all all the
money that you get over the last decade
or so it doesn't really go to you you
guys don't have all the basic
necessities right now you don't have any
food water electricity hospitals are
crumbling right now and they won't let
you flee because they need you as a
human shield what does it take for an
uprising to come if Hamas does not
represent you make it apparent that that
is true and take them out very simple we
don't have the Necessities now because
the Jews are not providing it for us
anymore the Jews decided that they
weren't going to give us water I or
dates I was ordering from jumon every
day now nothing nothing no
Al won deliver here juman says account
not active it's
active oh my jum I give is jtube all the
time and how many Jackie Mason jokes do
you
need we get
it what since when is it your job to
supply your opponents with water since
when is it your job to to take care of
your people apparently never for Hamas
that's the un's responsibity
responsibility that's their job ex just
look I'm sorry armed Revolt there you go
guess what you want the world to Rally
around you and for this to end tomorrow
overthrow Hamas fat you're the party out
there I guess that's the most likely in
the opposition everybody take up arms
right now and go take out Hamas in
whatever way seems necessary and y'all's
justice system over there and the rest
of the world will come marching in and
peace will be known in your land well
all those college students in the squad
would be left with far too much egg on
their face true from the river to the
there's peace oh boy I would absolutely
love to to proudly hold up a Palestinian
flag like you guys did it you guys beat
Hamas you guys beat your oppressors you
have your own State now ask Israel for a
little help I'm sure they'll give it to
you yeah except 57% of them are like I
kind of like
Hamas they are still Jews you know they
are still look Jews people who kill Jews
it's about the 57% people who kill Jew
so not all of them but it's enough and
that's the real reason the problem can't
be solved here's another claim from John
Oliver and it's always fun when it comes
to this it's actually all America's
fault it's worth noting that there is
one more major player in all of this
that I haven't mentioned yet and it's us
and I don't just mean the British who
are absolutely responsible for some of
this I'm talking about America because
this country has emphatically picked a
site in recent years we've given Israel
$3.8 billion a year in military aid and
you can make geopolitical Arguments for
why that is or isn't a valid thing to do
but it means we're heavily implicated in
everything you've just seen yeah it it
pales in comparison to the billions that
we give to Iran Palestine themselves uh
if you go to Libya Jordan Egypt all
these other nations who are not friendly
to the Jews so that's a first that's a
first uh yeah we give over4 billion
dollar a year to some of these countries
that hate them that doesn't even include
Iran with a billion dollars or so that
did or the $6 billion given that is now
refrozen I'm sure you guys could total
that up I'm going by by rot here yeah um
but this is also uh this goes to oh
there's another claim that he makes here
right is this or did I did we already oh
clip America's fault I guess just listen
to basam aramin a Palestinian whose
10-year-old daughter was killed by an
Israeli Border guard in 2007 my daughter
have been killed with America raer po
unfortunately from an American M16
unfortunately from an American G
American Uniform and the soldier have
trained in America so everything is
American right everything is American
and I know that is hard to here but the
fact is made in America is something
that we understandably love to brag
about when it's slapped on things that
we're proud of but unfortunately it's
not just tractors truck nuts and Toby
Keith songs sometimes it's stuff that's
killing
people uh here's the truth it's hamas's
fault let's just let's just be clear
about this so let's walk through October
7th Hamas brutally murdered 1,00
Israelis notice they counted down it
went up to 1400 yep and then the Israeli
government said actually now it's 1,200
sorry we overinflated it
yep did we say 8,000 we meant 80 now do
you hate the
Jews this is very true I heard Gaza is
almost out of children by the way yeah
you with this well half of their
population is children that's right yes
half of their population is children
how's that possible uh they've killed
the adults well we're not exactly
overflowing with Trojans here
okay this is not Magnum
country I look at the BR they get
pregnant plus I have like 75 of them
it's it's it's disgusting having kids is
easy when you can do it with your sister
that's
right it was the boning of sah Emma what
they I'm not
wrong they're wrong take it up with them
take it up with Hamas so America America
does provide Aid to Israel because It Is
neighbored by uh every single well they
all want to destroy yeah here's a map of
Israel in the Arab world just to be
clear since its Inception in 1948 Israel
has been at and I know some of you are
saying well they should have never been
allowed there okay fine they've been at
war with Egypt Jordan Syria Iraq
Hezbollah Hamas Iran by proxy like at
you do have to even if you just think
that the the Jews are wrong and you you
you hate them more than all these other
countries even though it's the only
place that has any type of basic human
rights um you still do have to
acknowledge that they might be a little
more on edge because they're surrounded
by people who want to eradicate them
just to be clear can you can we we at
least understand that why they might be
a little bit defensive also this is one
thing that I think is pretty important
for people to note and you'll hear
people talk about the radical uh Jews
who want to bring about the end times
right and they want certain areas and
temples for example to be cleared
there's not a lot of pring from the
Jewish people to be clear globally like
that's kind of Christian thing and then
you know um I don't know if it's prizing
so much as terrorizing from Islam but
the point is Christians want more
Christians I mean you even have Mormons
right they all go on missions trips uh
you have Jehovah's Witnesses who annoy
you at your door and then you have
Muslims who you know you convert uh or
you uh you die but Jews they're not
necessarily looking to invite more
people into the club even if you were to
go through their end time beliefs they
believe they will be Jews and there will
be non there will be Gentiles right they
don't have to eradicate all the Gentiles
Muslims do believe in AAL fate where
they have to wage a Jihad and in a
perfect world convert every single
person to Islam at the tip of a sword
that's a part of it so there is a big
difference where Jews if if if you don't
like them because they kind of just want
to be left to
themselves that that is historically
they kind of just want to have their own
space they're not looking to go to go
out into Iran and turn them into Jews
but if you do look at the Islamic World
they are constantly encroaching on
territory that they do not see as me as
Med their Puritan test of true Islam and
that's because of fundamental
differences in the faith even though we
say they're all aramic religions okay
just stop all right let's go to another
claim sorry did you want me to no we're
good yeah all right I know we're going
late today we have Pokemon or hate
symbol oh Lord no no no keep going then
claim number six the E of course he
comes out and makes the lazy argument uh
that people have used since John Lenin
and something something give peace a
chance ceasefire I don't have a solution
for peace in the Middle East and even if
I did which again don't this really
would be the worst voice in which to
relay that message hey he's right it
does seem to me personally that a
ceasefire has to be the first step yeah
okay you don't get to have a ceasefire
with a terrorist group and by the way
there are other times that ceasefires
have been broken by Hamas when Israel
said okay ceasefire so let's go to a
let's go to August 2014 we're going to
before we get to October 7th August 2014
3-day ceasefire was broken by Hamas in 2
hours yeah so so they so here's they 72
hours they thought they thought you said
two yeah so it was supposed to be a 3
like look look let's go three days uh
uhhuh B baby steps not killing Jews
right and then let's see if we can build
some momentum with this they were like
okay and after two hours like I had my
fingers
crossed December hate was just boiling
inside of me I couldn't two hours was a
long time bro had to get it out December
2008 Hamas started launching Rockets
into Israel during a ceasefire period in
response to Israel destroying a Hamas
tunnel which they just admitted was a
Hamas tunnel not the people a Hamas
tunnel not a gazen tunnel look look
calling this is very very lazy and I did
a video a long time ago on the peace
symbol and John lennin and give peace a
chance peace is a two-way street period
or you have to blockade the road if
you're driving down a free a two-lane
two-lane road and there's an oncoming
truck and you don't want to hit him you
don't want to head- on collision but he
does guess what there's going to be a
head- on collision you only miss each
other through an agreement where you
both don't want to die peace cannot
exist with a terrorist group people who
say ceasefire when will the violence
stop hold on a second you're saying
nothing this is Goofy silly dumb
talk it makes no sense you're dealing
with terrorists who want to eradicate an
entire ethnicity of ethnicity religion
however you want a culture of people
calling for a ceasefire when civilians
were raped murdered kidnapped by
terrorists is supporting
[Music]
terrorism
hey ceasefire ceasefire everyone calm
down hey ceasefire calm down
guys and I'm going to we're going to
keep doing that until people like John
Oliver stop saying such stupid
things you guys can comment below I know
you're thinking like do we need another
ceasefire sketch we have a lot of
Revenge films in in the hopper right now
the list is there's more to come by the
way you know what you need to do we're
going to have a meeting and until that
meeting where we can talk about whether
we're going to have a ceasefire or not
we're going to continue kicking your
butt you guys want to talk fine but
these bombs they're are dropping I got
targets laid out for days if you want to
if you want to talk about a ceasefire we
we can but after we've come to some sort
of agreement not we'll pause and let you
guys regroup and the ceasefire just
didn't work and we couldn't come terms
after 3 days uh and now you guys are
ready to attack us again I'm sorry
that's what they do that's their well
and we've covered that right now I want
to cover right that John Oliver is a
liar so we all know that Hamas is a liar
but the fact that John Oliver in Western
media is being an apologist for them he
tries to pretend as though he's going to
be objective but he's nothing more than
a propagandist the problem is he's a
propagandist for an actual terrorist
organization in Aus skating the real
information and Aus skating the
information that people would actually
want to know if they were trying to at
the very least you know create their own
educated or come to an educated
conclusion they would be incapable of
doing that if they believed John Oliver
not only because he uses hamas's numbers
as it relates to death tolls not only
because he completely denies the
historical context of Israel and Hamas
not only because he misrepresents how
many people in Gaza feel as though they
are accurately represented by Hamas not
only because he M misrepresents the fact
that Hamas uses those people as human
Shields not only because he
misrepresents the fact that Israel has
actually helped Hamas help sorry the
people of Palestine in multiple
instances or the fact that Israel has
honored ceasefires which Hamas Has
Broken if you were to watch John Oliver
and rah rah rah in the comment section
and I see those people in the comment
section maybe we'll go and leave a
couple of comments because hey you know
what you can swarm our Channel I don't
care if nothing else you've got to
remember that he devoted six minutes to
criticizing Hamas who by his own
admission kind of has the extermination
of Jews in their
Charter and 20 going after Israel hey
guess how we know you're a propagandist
but people think that it's people think
that it's somehow High bre because he
has an English accent and he puts up
salon or slate as a
source it by the way it doesn't offend
me as a host of a show I think it
offends us as a as comedians what a
salon like like a place where you get
your hair done you would think so but
it's also that's where he's getting his
news it's a website for feminists and uh
you know people who hate themselves gay
interesting okay you guys can you know
what go ahead comment below uh let John
Oliver know what you think hopefully
this was fair you can go and I encourage
you to watch his entire video in its
full context has he talked about uh the
UK and their uh freedom of the lack of
freedom of speech yet oh no he
absolutely has not he's talked about the
myth of cancel culture where it's just
people complaining about stuff when it's
actually accountability and he is when
people talk about a neutered comedian
they're talking about John Oliver this
is a guy who everything he says is safe
and he does target people it's just safe
to Target conservatives to Target
Christians and to Target like Fox News
as though at this point they're even a
worthy adversary so if you are watching
right now on YouTube I don't know why
you are if you're watching on Rumble you
get to continue watching we actually
have our exclusive uh we're bringing
back it was banned on YouTube The Old
Death Wish yeah parody that we did a
long time ago was death wish 14 I
believe uh the transition we can't run
that on
YouTube no there's no sex and we are
going to play Pokemon or racial slur uh
watching un Rumble click that button
none of this happens without you without
mug club and certainly none of the
investigative journalism YouTube p
[Applause]
[Music]
stuff